[Music]
did you know that 80% of enterprise data
is largely unstructured and 70% a large
percentage of it is in the form of
freeform text by preformed text I mean
we see a lot of enterprises sitting on
dark data and this data can be a
document goldmine a lot of these
documents are PDFs emails contracts
think comments tweets tickets patent
files application forms and this data is
only going to grow we see that a lot of
organizations of a strong need to make
sense of realms of unstructured data and
if you're an organization that is
already aware of this problem and you're
trying to analyze these documents as
part of your business workflows it's
likely you're spending a large amount of
time money and resources to analyze
these documents and the process may also
be error-prone what if we told you we
have a document understanding solution
that can help make your life easier
without breaking the bank
hi everyone my name is Sudhir awone
Gauri and I'm the product manager for
document understanding AI here at Google
cloud today I'll be walking you through
a quick overview of the solution
I'll try to unbundle the solution a
little bit deep and deep dive a little
bit into what makes up the solution in
the components of the solution I also
have some exciting partner integrations
and stories to share with you
I'll also be joined on stage by ANCA
Konzelman the director of engineering at
Director of Product Management at Iron
Mountain and she'll be talking about
four key case studies and vertical
solutions that Iron Mountain is
investing in we'll also be joined by
Milan Li our customer engineer who'll
walk us through a demo of a patent
application that has been processed and
to end from unstructured data to struck
should data using document understanding
AI let's get started
so document understanding AI is a
solution that enables you to automate
key document processing workflows and
extract valuable knowledge from within
those documents how do we do that well
document understanding AI is powered by
our powerful natural language
capabilities knowledge capabilities and
vision OCR capabilities so unbundling
and looking through the solution a
little bit we enable you to come in to
GCP or our partner solutions with
unstructured data a lot of forms
patterns contracts and all of those
document goal line that we referred to a
while ago we we enable you to classify
those documents organize those documents
meaningfully using our auto ml
technologies we also enable you to
extract key value pairs and entities
from those documents again using a
combination of natural language region
OCR and our ml capabilities and if a
business were to add your own schema we
also have knowledge capabilities through
a new alpha version called knowledge
service this enables you to construct a
knowledge graph out of your unstructured
data and map it to your own ERP systems
so that you can start to extract
insights from those documents and
convert that unstructured data into
structured data let me show you a quick
demo this demo we have a knowledge base
it contains Wikipedia articles about a
wide variety of topics and all there are
48 documents one of the documents is
about steam engines so here you see the
content of the Wikipedia article about
steam engine now let's say I want to
know something else to me
you see in our basic search we have a
result that matches on some keywords but
it's not semantically similar to the
query we go to the semantic match we see
that the answer matches the meaning of
the query if we view it in the document
we can see where in the article the
passage is coming from another one of
our articles is about Doctor Who famous
British TV show well let's say I want to
know the plot of Doctor Who so I'll
enter semantically similar query the
basic search results we don't really see
who Doctor Who is but in semantic match
we end up with a great description of
Doctor Who he's the primary character
he's from a different planet and he goes
by the name the doctor now let's say I
want to dive deeper and I want to answer
a specific question search result is
poor
what we see that the question answered
the question is actually in the document
the answer is 826 826 Doctor Who
installments since 1963 let's say we
want to ask another question when did it
first air and sure enough the answer is
in the document and we're able to find
it and services so that's some of our
knowledge capabilities for you know that
we also have a lot of our custom key
value pairs and custom knowledge
grappling capability so that the same
use case can apply to various verticals
and industries given your business
schema so in a nutshell what document
understanding gives you is through our
partners solutions you'll be able to
organize your documents classify and
extract key value pairs and insights
from within those documents and automate
your business workflows using the
extracted insights so enough talk let me
dive right into some of our partner
solutions announcing some of our early
launch partners our lead launch partner
is Iron Mountain which is fully
integrated with the document are
standing AI solution and our
capabilities we also have key
partnerships and integrations with
uipath ignite box
Tahlia DocuSign and Accenture let's dive
right into some key use cases and some
exciting examples our first partner
ignite has used document understanding
AI to detect anomalous activity or file
downloads on patents and the ACE and
contracts now ignite protect enables
well an organization or an administrator
to know when significant downloads of
very sensitive documents have happened
over over the past couple of weeks and
the way it does that is
ignite product builds a personalized
profile of the common file types
accessed by let's say John Smith well
that's entirely hypothetical I don't
know a John Smith sorry John Smith but
let's say John Smith accesses a lot of
pattern files 250 odd pattern files
within a week whereas his normal per
profile typically access about two or
three contracts four or five patterns
during work week now with document
understanding a I ignite product is able
to classify contracts employee lists
invoices NDA's and various document
formats and flag sensitive documents
when a large file activity happens so
that insider attacks and espionage
attempts can be thwarted by
organizations
that's a cool real-world application of
document or assigning AI for sensitive
document workloads that we see apply to
various industries say H HR files
detecting GD P are compliant so on and
so forth another partner application of
document understanding a I was auto
tagging forms using using document
understanding AI DocuSign are a
transaction management partner has used
document understand EA I to detect
bounding boxes on farms the key is case
here let's say we have a w-9 form we're
able to accurately identify bounding
boxes trained on thousands of documents
and also associate those bounding boxes
with signature fields name fields
checkboxes so on and so forth to go from
an entirely untagged document that was
manually tagged before into a fully
automatic tagged form that darkus sign
then has launched into their mobile
applications I have a cool demo to show
you this doesn't have a talk track but
I'll try to make sense of it for you
so let's say we have an NDA that has a
bunch of fields a set of five fields or
so and this NDA needs to be signed by
one party so the sign the sender let's
say Tamara
since this NDA out to Martin now auto
tagging kicks in and we're using
doctrine understanding AI will
automatically able to identify what's
the date sign what's a text field what's
the signature field now we're using a
combination of NLP auto ml and natural
language to do this
that's it earlier this was an entirely
manual process that Tamara had to go and
identify which fields needed signatures
using document understanding AI we are
automatically able to identify when a
signature the word signature is close to
a signature field what is the date sign
field versus a leasing date so on and so
forth so that's document understanding
AI a powerful combination of very
technologies using a combination of NLP
OCR and our own ml technologies another
partner uipath has used document
understanding AI for automating that
invoice processes so here's an example
of an invoice as you can see the invoice
is in a tabular format there is a lot of
handwritten text on the invoice there is
a stamp in there so we're able to
accurately identify key value pairs from
within that invoice taking a closer look
at it as you can see we also share the
confidence course for the key value
pairs that we've extracted from that
invoice now if there were a human in the
loop we also enable the human to take a
look at the confidence course so there
can be further downstream processing on
those invoices so the entire manual
automate manual process of invoice
processing is fully automated using
document understanding AI a similar use
case around invoice processing is
cognitive invoicing using document
understanding AI that our partner Talia
has integrated with Talia uses document
understanding AI for automatically
extracting invoice data and using their
platform their suppliers and buyers are
able to coordinate on invoices wherever
there is verification needed but then a
large part of the invoice processing is
automated using document understanding
moving as Talia says moving out of the
dark ages of manual invoice processing
using the u AI
our final partner integration is with
Accenture Saga an NLP platform powered
by documentary sani AI and some other
key third-party solutions uses our
energy extraction knowledge graphing and
question answering service to solve key
question answering and document
understanding workflows for Accenture's
customers with that let me hand a word
to Anka for a deep dive on Iron Mountain
insight and for key case studies thanks
very much
my name is Anka I am the director of
product management for Iron Mountain
insight and I'm gonna tell you a little
bit about our platform and some use
cases that we're enabling to drive value
for our customers so the the the office
experience and many of us work with
information we know what this is like
right there's a ton of data but finding
the right stuff when you need it is
incredibly hard still so this quote all
you know it's from 1982 all right think
about that so we think it's time to fix
it
and our partnership with Google is
really all about that our customers are
at various stages of digital
transformation which for them is about
driving value from their information
transforming to a new way of working and
frankly reducing their risk from the
information that they're storing there
are plenty of statistics that actually
you know she mentioned already right so
huge amounts of storage very little of
that information actually being used and
document understanding combined with
Iron Mountain's information management
and information governance expertise
really enables us to to get to a point
where we can at scale and as a service
deliver the value out of all of that
information and again I said you know we
come from sort of an information
governance background so we are also
focused on making sure that you can be
compliant with regulations that may
apply to you as you're doing and doing
that
so I'll briefly walk through some
high-level information about the
platform and then dig into the use cases
to show you how that all works so the
platform there really get a sort of
three steps if you will right at first
is ingestion for us ingestion is really
broad right so we have customers who
store physical information with us could
be paper could be tapes and we want to
make sure that we can allow them to pull
all of that information into the
platform in order to enrich it and
process it it could also be digital
information right so ingestion from
various different sources from various
different types of Nohr forms and in
various formats video images documents
all of those various sources that sedara
mentioned earlier second step really
done is all about processing that
content we built a cloud native platform
on top of TCP so we're leveraging all
the power of GCP in order to store and
process the information we're using
document understanding AI in order to
classify and enrich the content and
really it's all about three primary use
cases if you will at a high level that
we want to drive right one is around
analytics right how do I now make this
information valuable to a user
the second is around information
governance now that I know what I have
what are the policies that I need to
apply how long should I keep it when do
I need to protect it because it has
personal or more sensitive information
in it and then the third one is around
workflow automation and we'll walk
through use cases that illustrate each
of those items in the end it's about
adding structure to that big portion of
your content that is today unstructured
so the first use case is in oil and gas
so we store incredibly varying types of
things for our oil and gas customers
could be ginormous maps that get scanned
and then processed could be seismic data
that is on tape
could be well logs that could be you
know dozens to hundreds of feet long and
we help a ingest all of that information
and then using the document
understanding AI we extract information
that helps us frankly enable the
geoscientists to make use of this
information so all of the various
content can you imagine if you're a
scientist trying to find the information
you need to evaluate where you might
want to drill or what the value of a
certain well is all right you're going
across paper maps at Iron Mountain
you're going to tape potentially for
seismic and one of the challenges is you
just don't ever know whether you
actually got access to everything that
you need so what we're doing here is
processing the information again using
document understanding AI we also can
enrich the information with external
metadata sources so it's about pulling
as much information metadata together
from using AI as well as from existing
sources and putting that all together in
a visual search UI that allows to your
scientists to search for it in a way
that makes sense
alright so instead of spending half your
time looking for the stuff you can now
spend most of your time actually
analyzing it so the search UI allows
access by location so if I'm looking for
a certain spot on the map that I want to
evaluate I can get right to the
information that's pertinent to me
across the various assets that I'm
dealing with we use for example a
similarity search so that if I see a
certain pattern or a sort of intrusion
that might be of interest to me I can
quickly find all the assets that have a
similar pattern and and all of that
really is about faster decision-making
and and better analysis second use case
a bit more you know sort of text
document heavy in this case we're
dealing with mortgage and really
enabling that automation of a very very
manual workflow right we all might think
that you know this stuff is all online
now we fill it all out online you'd be
surprised most of it becomes paper
somewhere along the line so it's a very
very heavy manual process
and as a result it's also a very slow
process so this particular use case is
all about you know taking a process from
multiple days to hours right
for this particular use case it's also
very illustrative of the power of
document understanding ai what we're
doing here is we're looking at a loan
file and we're asking two questions is
it a complete and is it accurate right
so in order to decide whether a mortgage
file is complete I got to understand
what documents I got classify the
documents compare against a list of per
you know location what's actually
required right what defines complete
making sure that all those documents are
here now we dig in right is it accurate
so this is where we have to pull
information whether it's a name a social
security number it could be an APR there
are lots and lots and lots of
extractions that happen across those
different documents and two things right
one do I have everything filled out do I
have a signature where I'm expecting a
signature do I have a name where I'm
expecting a name do I have a stamp from
you know a certain maybe regulatory
group that needs to you know bless
something all of those things need to
get checked then I need to look across
the documents right do I have the same
name with the same social security
number in all of them is the APR the
same and you know essentially
identifying did somebody put the wrong
paper in the wrong file or is a document
filled in incorrectly or incompletely so
document understanding helps us to do
all of those things and then from a
workflow automation perspective we can
output that to enable an RPA process
that now can be much much more automated
rather than manual so when you're
thinking about you know the top of this
particular slide right all those little
people that's where all the time is
being spent that's where the
inefficiency comes in for the processor
that's where the wait time comes in from
a customer experience perspective right
so we're really looking for here is to
drive better customer experience
for the actual applicant as well as time
and cost savings for the processor and
then finally of course the automation to
enable the entire workflow to be
automated end to end the second thing
that that is really important is once we
have all of this rich information there
are other use cases that can be enabled
right so if a mortgage processor wants
to understand how their are doing with
respect to compliance for fair lending
right they have all this rich
information that they can now use to
understand how they're doing right are
they actually well-positioned or do they
have an issue and what can they do about
it right so the analytics on top once
we've done all of this work there are
myriad of other use cases that can be
enabled for that particular customer
another very document-centric process is
HR right so employee records this
particular use case is focused on
privacy so gdpr
who's mentioned right so personal
information and complying with GD P R
really means you have to be able to
understand where you have personal
information about your employees in this
case and you have to be able to get to
it quickly right an employee says hey I
want to know what you are keeping about
me what personal information you're
storing of mine I need to be able to get
to that content quickly I need to be
sure that I'm finding all of it
right and I need to be able to actually
give it to the employee if they ask for
it so processing documents of various
from various sources and in various
formats right so I've been at Iron
Mountain for a really long time when I
first got hired we filled out paper
right so my my records probably are in
paper so pulling all of that in being
able to image that content and allow
that to be commingled with content that
may have been collected electronically
just you know a couple of months ago or
last year it's very very important and
being able to have the ability to
understand where that content in the
document is and and whether or not I'm
actually dealing with sensitive
information or personal information as
opposed to just you know here's a big
pile of stuff that may or may not be
relevant again enables companies to not
only be compliant but be efficient in
responding to requests so the other
thing about these things is you can't
keep stuff forever anymore right so
retention policy you know a lot of
companies for a long time actually you
know kind of the default was well I keep
everything forever so that way I'm not
deleting anything that I shouldn't be
well GDP are actually sort of ends the
era of everything forever retention
policy so now that we have this
information we have it classified we
understand who it's for when an employee
leaves the company we have an obligation
to actually be able to get rid of that
information within the retention period
that is is within the compliance for the
privacy regulation right so classifying
the content understanding that it is
employee information that pertains to a
certain employee now also allows us to
get rid of the information when we need
to so that's where the policy Plus
document understanding AI really you
know sort of comes together to help
companies do the right thing at the
right time this next one I'm going to
dig into a little bit deeper so this is
you know actually we hear it a lot from
our customers it doesn't really matter
what kind of company you are you
probably have customer contracts we all
hope we have many right at Iron Mountain
that's something like four hundred
thousand so very simple things get
really hard when you're trying to do
them a gock across a big huge pile of
stuff like that right so first of all
they tend to be kind of distributed
different products and services
different regions different acquisitions
that they may have come from right so
the stuff is all over the place so
simple simple questions like what are
all the contracts for this particular
customer already hard
right people poke around in lots of
different places and they hope again
they hope they find all the relevant
information but they may not the other
thing is you know things like well who
has non-standard payment terms how do
you answer that you get to read a lot of
documents alright that's how it's done
today so then you look at you know more
complex questions like which contracts
have a limit of liability for data
breach above a million dollars and now
we're looking at document understanding
AI as a really really powerful tool to
allow those natural language questions
to actually be answered so this
particular use case is where we work
very closely with Google on using the
knowledge capabilities that sedara
introduced earlier to really empower
users to find this type of information
very very quickly so let me show you a
couple of examples that illustrate what
the UI looks like and what the
experience is for a user so this is our
simple you know I need all the contracts
for a given customer now notice in this
case we're actually dealing with the
salesperson right so another thing that
that is really powerful here is that
there are multiple stakeholders
potentially within your company that
need to access this content and we can
allow each and every one of them to have
the benefit of accessing this rich
information now very quickly so in this
particular use case you're going from
poking around asking people getting to
different repositories to essentially
one-click what we've done is anything
that we extract we allow you to use as a
facet or as a widget I can pin those on
my UI so if I'm usually looking for
things by customer name I can actually
just pin that right to my UI if I'm
looking for a certain customer start
typing in the name or just click on the
one that I'm looking for and all the
documents that I need are there with one
click all right so incredibly efficient
to get to what still is a fairly simple
answer second one a little bit more
complex right so now who has
non-standard payment terms right this is
actually quite a common issue for
companies and it's incredibly hard to
get to so again today first of all I got
to find all of the contracts in all the
repositories but then how do I figure
out what the payment terms are so I
might do a keyword search and I get to
the right section of the contract which
I then get to read all right so still
very manual very sort of a person doing
lots of reading to get to it here what
we can do is narrow it down perhaps by
customer if that's what we want to do
narrow it down perhaps by agreement type
so the classification that we've done
but then really looking at the document
understanding AI to extract the
pertinent information and letting me
essentially say okay well you know what
30 days is my standard payment terms so
anything 60 or 90 give me those
because those are the ones that I need
to focus in on again going from who
knows how many hours of work to a few
clicks that give me the right result set
and this is my favorite one so when you
think about contracts think about
perhaps an M&A scenario we've just
bought a company your GC walks by and
says hey how many customers within that
population that we've just inherited
have a limitation of Liability above a
million dollars how many do you know
have a non-standard you know whatever
closet might be right that generally is
where you know forget your weekend
you're going to be reading for a long
time and frankly in an M&A case there is
you know dozens of people locked in to a
room for could be days could be weeks
depending on how big it is reading
literally reading through documents so
again what we can do here is define what
is standard what is non-standard we can
look for those things using the
knowledge capability
that come with the document
understanding AI and extract that
information and give it to the lawyers
at their fingertips within again a few
clicks with the ability to filter based
on different types of documents
different regions if that's what they're
looking for all of that information is
literally a click to get to so I hope
these use cases illustrated the power of
document understanding AI and what we
can do to really drive value for
customers from using these types of
technologies as part of our platform we
think it's important that we can deliver
an end-to-end solution so that customers
can really take advantage of all of the
benefits that come with these really
advanced and great capabilities that
that Google is providing and get to a
much faster time to value than you know
trying to sort of build it all yourself
build a UI all of that stuff
infrastructure all of those good fun
things that go around it
so again the platform very flexible we
think it's important that you can do
that across various content types from
various content sources in various
formats we have an example of you know
for example the the marketing department
right those guys are dealing with videos
they're dealing with images they're
dealing with you know data sheets lots
of different content types
but when I'm looking for something it's
usually not by document type it's by
topic it's by you know I'm looking for a
certain country for certain languages
for a certain product but I want all the
content for that product or for that
language so again very important to go
across those different formats and types
for us right again defensible compliant
is very important so we want to make
sure that when you're classifying you're
also able to take advantage of that so
that you can drive appropriate policy
for those documents right how do I now
leverage that the fact that I know what
I have
right and that I can use it but how do I
also make sure that I'm treating it
appropriately that I'm retaining it for
as long as I need to that I'm protecting
it because it's sensitive or personal
information that I'm dealing with here
and and in doing that in one platform
across multiple stakeholders across
multiple different use cases so you do
all of the hard work once you classify
you and rich but then you benefit for
multiple stakeholders multiple use cases
advanced analytics on top once I've done
sort of the automation piece to start so
I hope this was helpful and illustrative
of what we're trying to do here and I'm
gonna pass it over to good afternoon my
name is Milan Lee and I'm a machine
learning specialist at Google cloud
we've heard already how great the
document understanding AI solution
really is let me go ahead and show you
the details of it the technology of it
and I will even show you a quick demo on
how it works so for my demo I'm going to
be analyzing patterns data
I'll pretend LM attorney at a patent
attorney firm and I want to be able to
gain competitive insights on what
different companies are doing what their
product innovation roadmap is and one
legal source of that is to look into
pan's data patents actually have a lot
of rich information that you cannot get
anywhere else you cannot get from
journals you cannot get from conferences
those are usually pretty proprietary
information but that happens to be
shared so it really helps me to
understand what are the active payers in
the market and for every single product
the challenge of you know reading
through patents is enormous and let me
explain to you what those challenges are
and how we can use AI specifically
within understanding I to help us solve
the problem
so we're looking at two different
patents from the US side by side for
each patent what's really interesting to
a patent attorney is when is a patent
filed and there are various dates within
the patent so we have a the data patent
that was approved and we also have a
date for when the patent was initially
filed for me to be automatically extract
those two key fields are already really
worth to use AI for I want to be able to
make sure that when I stretch out those
fields I can properly populate them in
the database in the exact column and in
the exact format and not mix up those
two dates we also see a lot of different
and structured data on here so for
example we have a title of the patent
and the title cells sometimes pretty
generic but sometimes it's pretty
specific okay so I want to be able to
extract those key information as well
and of course there are illustrations
within the patents that often tell us
what is going on with this invention
what are the components that go towards
it so what if I have an AI tool that can
help me to automatically understand in a
straight out the documents so then I
don't have to manually review it do data
entry for it and then crop out the image
and store it you know that would save me
a lot of human hours so this is a pretty
huge endeavor to do and what if I want
to really expand this work beyond just
US patents what if I want you to start
looking at European patents that also
come in different format from us they
have different nomenclature different
fields different titles different ways
of expressing things and let's go ahead
and couple this with the challenge of
having different languages so we can
have German French in addition to
English and many other European
languages well how can we use AI to
automate the ingestion understanding and
processing of artists documents are in
different formats different languages
and unify them in one single environment
that's really where the AI would come in
okay so let me just walk through the
lifecycle of understanding a patent
document and I want to throw out the
caveat that this is not the only life
that in a patent can adopt it really
depends on what your use case is but for
my use case what I really want to do is
just to ingest data and then process it
and be able to store it in a structured
format so let's start off with kind of
the ingestion layer so I want to be able
to find an economical option to store
all my new patents and be able to
archive more old patents every year in
US alone there are at least 600,000
patents are green files so we will need
a scalable way to store all these
patents there are current in PDF format
into a raw on storage area okay and in
this solution doesn't only ingest
documents in PDF format it can ingest
pictures images videos so forth and so
on
so after we ingest the data I want to be
able to kick out documents that are not
looking like patents right so in this
case we really want to use a computer
vision model to help us fine tune and
kick out those non patent documents and
then we'll move on to the value at the
process which is to apply OCR on it so
OCR is just an acronym for optical
optical character recognition which is
used to detect and extract the text in a
image and then write it out to a file
format raw text format so why do we need
to a straddle to a raw text format so it
turns out that there are a lot of
natural language processing that we can
do on top of this raw text for example
we can apply a content categorization
model okay so what does that do it will
basically scan through the raw text and
it will identify what is the topic of
his patent so instead of me reviewing
the patent manually now we can use AI to
help us understand what the content is
for example is dispatching about medical
technology is it about cryptocurrencies
is it about computer vision or is it
about other things right so we can have
an AI to automatically understanding for
us and then after that process we can
extract out the specific entities that
I'm interested in so those entities
could be the title the description of
the patent the different dates in the
patent anything that I want to define a
specific specific entities I can
basically fine-tune it in my model and
then I want then do an object detection
so the after detection is basically
finding the images and signals within
the image or PDF document and be able to
crop out that image identified XY
coordinates of that image and store it
in the database
and then lastly you have a structure way
to analyze the data so that's pretty
much what I want to go through let's go
ahead and run a demo really quick I'm
going to log into my system ok so I'm
going to launch a shell script this show
script will basically help me to invoke
all the AI services that I will use to
generate the classification models and
LP models and object detection models ok
and and then I'll show you the end I'll
come of it so I'll go I will go ahead
and launch the script and I actually
launched it before the demo and can we
go back to the slides so while this is
launching while the transcript is
launching let me go through what each
model is doing so the first model is
basically classifying between the
European Patent US Patent and another
category called data sheet which is just
more detail specs about a patent itself
so in order to classify these specific
categories we'll have to use a custom
model for it because the generic model
that Google has as an API will not be
specific enough for these three
categories so in my demo
I used a roughly 500 samples to train
the model
I was able to get very close to 100%
decision and 100% recall for my model
performance those two metrics are
usually used to determine how robust the
model is so with 500 samples with the
writing a single line of tensorflow code
without having to do any programming I'm
able to find in my model to
differentiate between the different
patterns so this is the where I will
filter out the data sheets and then move
on to the next value added process so we
apply OCR on it so as you can see
everything that was inside Pat in PDF is
now converted to a raw text that's not
really interesting yet the next
interesting part is yet another AI we
want to categorize the content within
the patents so by scanning through the
content being able to pass the different
sentences being able to draw a semantic
meaning from the corpus in the text
we're able to determine what is the
category or what is the content for this
patent okay so right here in my demo I
only created three different categories
but this can be as many categories as
you need for your business domain and
again I only have to train the model
with very very few samples in order to
get this kind of accuracy and position
in my model so what this is telling me
for example is every time when I run a
model when I invoke a model I would be
able to get a probability on whether
this is a this is a pattern relating to
metal medical tech cryptocurrencies or
computer vision so given that we know
the content and then we want to extract
out the specific entities this is pretty
hard to do you know Google or has some
featuring api's to extract out common
entities like objects names landmarks
etc but not really specific to patent
documents so this is where we'll also
use auto ml to fine-tune the model and
external only the
and I want so remember this isn't
trivial because we have different
languages for our patents and we have
different formats so the positioning of
the information might be different among
other patterns you have the with the
Auto ml that's within the solution we
are able to fine-tune it a strategy
exact entity that we need with a pretty
high accuracy for most of the fields and
then lastly we want to draw a bounding
box again this is very important to
understand the illustration of the
invention itself so the after detection
technology will basically identify any
objects that you want to identify so
let's say if there are multiple objects
here you can choose to identify the most
important object to you and just extract
that image with the XY coordinates and
in a family you know we saw how we can
kind of lunch around the instructure
data and then we finally kind of arrived
to the destination which is to have a
very structured way to understand our
data so in this case I chose to use
bigquery to store all the data this can
be other kinds of you know analytical
database the destination can be maybe
another service for example it can be
like this
okay so this is within the document
solution a document understanding a
isolation that would help to basically
find Association and relationship among
your data so for example I may have
multiple inventors for a particular
technology and I want to be able to find
relationships among authors inventors or
among different content area within my
patents so another service is really
helpful visually to find those
relationships okay
Thank You Milan before I wrap quick show
of hands so we've gone through about
seven partner stories we've gone through
four case studies that anchors pointed
out an Iron Mountain and the patent use
case how many of these use cases
resonate with some of the document
processing workflows you've seen in your
company or business well pretty much
everybody's working with contracts I
assume how many of you have not seen any
of these document use cases have you
missed any we got everything I see one
well I hope that by the end of this
session you're as excited as I am in
trying out some of our document
understanding capabilities our partner
integrations make it really easy for you
it's a fastest time to value for you to
get these deployments up and running we
see that a lot of companies across
verticals to highlight a few we see
energy companies that try to automate
some of the geophysicists workflows and
evaluate the risks associated with new
sites use document understanding AI or
can use document understanding AI to
identify let's say well in reservoir
parametres within very technical
well geophysical documents that require
a lot of ml expertise
mattias providers can use document
understanding ai to automate and figure
out what's a servicing document what's
an origination document and we've seen
that these kind of classifications not
just for mortgage documents our document
classification in general has given over
or up to 96% precision ignite for
instance has got 97.3% position on
classifying security documents health
care companies can use document
understanding ai and their clinical
trial processing there's a lot of
doctors patient notes that you need to
analyze that get very technical and you
may want to analyze well what's a dosage
amount or what's influenza or what's a
certain symptom within within that
patient note
and we see these vertical use cases
expand across multiple industries
contracts for instance is omnipresent
across multiple verticals in contract
processing is something that all of
these industries can analyze using
document understanding AI and retail
customers for instance can analyze
customer feedback yeah I think think
tweets comments tickets service tickets
that the Kami analyzes all of this
unstructured data can be converted into
structured data using our document
understanding AI tools with that I would
love to encourage you to try plow the
Google comm solutions document
understanding pleased with it and
provide your feedback we're always
amazed at what what new use cases our
customers come up with and sometimes we
are surprised by them so please feel
free to give us feedback I'll hang
around for questions but thank you so
much for attending and hope you try out
document understanding AI
[Music]